Save now at Whole Foods Market. It's the Summer Splash event, with great everyday prices on 365 brand ground beef for the grill and ice cream for dessert. They have yellow sales signs on ready to cook beef or chicken kebabs too. Level up with savory marinate, spices and rubs, and complete your cookout with a crowd-pleasing cherry pie and their balsamic chicken salad. Available at the prepared foods counter. Get Summer Splash Savings now at Whole Foods Market. Speaking of Psychology is taking a summer break, so we're rerunning one of our favorite episodes from the past. In 2021, I talked to psychologist Kate Sweeney about the particular stress of waiting and living with uncertainty.
现在就在全食超市（Whole Foods Market）省钱。这是夏季狂欢活动，格栅用 365 品牌碎牛肉和甜点冰淇淋每天都有优惠的好价格。他们还为准备烹饪的牛肉或鸡肉烤肉串准备了黄色的促销标志。用美味的腌料、香料和调味汁来提升格调，并搭配大受欢迎的樱桃派和香醋鸡肉沙拉，为您的户外野炊画上圆满句号。熟食柜台有售。现在就去全食超市享受夏季狂欢优惠吧。《心理学畅谈》正在进行暑假休息，所以我们将重播过去我们最喜欢的剧集之一。2021 年，我与心理学家凯特·斯威尼（Kate Sweeney）探讨了等待和与不确定性共存的特殊压力。
We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of Psychology, we'll be back with new episodes on August 23rd. Thank you for listening. Is there anything more agonizing than having to wait for something important? You know that feeling of hoping for good news while bracing for the worst? Time seems to crawl in periods of high-stakes uncertainty, such as for a job applicant waiting to find out whether they got their dream job, or a high school senior waiting for word from colleges,
我们希望您喜欢这期来自档案的节目。《心理学畅谈》将于 8 月 23 日携新节目回归。感谢您的收听。有什么比等待重要的事情更痛苦的吗？你知道那种怀揣好消息的希望同时又在为最坏情况做心理准备的感觉吗？在高度不确定性的时期，时间似乎过得很慢，例如求职者等待得知他们是否得到了梦寐以求的工作，或者高中毕业生等待大学的录取通知，
or a patient awaiting biopsy results. And since COVID-19 entered our lives, the whole world has gotten a crash course in waiting and worrying, as we've all hoped for the end of this agonizing pandemic. What makes waiting so stressful? How does the stress of waiting differ from other types of stress? What kinds of waiting periods are the most difficult? Do some people have an easier time waiting than others? And what's the relationship between waiting and worrying?
或者等待活检结果的患者。自从新冠肺炎进入我们的生活以来，全世界都上了一堂关于等待和担忧的速成课，因为我们都期盼着这场痛苦的大流行早日结束。是什么让等待如此煎熬？等待的压力与其他类型的压力有何不同？什么样的等待期最困难？有些人是否比其他人更容易等待？等待和担忧之间有什么关系？
Is worrying always bad? And if you're in a period of anxious waiting, are there strategies you can use to lessen your anxiety and make the time pass more easily? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Kate Sweeney, a professor of psychology at the University of California Riverside. Dr. Sweeney researches how people cope with acute uncertainty. Her lab has studied people experiencing tense times in their lives, including law school graduates awaiting
担忧总是坏事吗？如果你正处于焦虑的等待期，有哪些策略可以用来减轻焦虑，让时间过得更快？欢迎收看《心理学畅谈》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是加州大学河滨分校心理学教授凯特·斯威尼博士。斯威尼博士研究人们如何应对急性不确定性。她的实验室研究了经历人生紧张时期的人们，包括等待法学硕士毕业生的
news about the bar exam, patients awaiting biopsy results, and voters awaiting the outcome of a presidential election. In recent years, she's become interested in exploring how getting into a state of flow can help people cope with this type of uncertainty. She also studies how doctors can talk to their patients to lessen the patient's anxiety. She has published dozens of peer-reviewed research studies and received APA's 2016 award for Distinguished Scientific Early Career Contributions to Psychology. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Sweeney. Thanks so much for having me. Let's talk about how the stress of waiting differs from other types of stress. For example, you might think that receiving a bad medical diagnosis would be more stressful than waiting for the diagnosis, but that's not necessarily
关于律师资格考试的消息、等待活检结果的患者以及等待总统大选结果的选民。近年来，她开始对探索如何进入心流状态来帮助人们应对这种不确定性产生兴趣。她还研究医生如何与患者交谈以减轻患者的焦虑。她发表了数十篇同行评审的研究报告，并获得了美国心理学协会 2016 年杰出科学早期职业贡献奖。谢谢你加入我们，斯威尼博士。非常感谢邀请我。让我们来谈谈等待的压力与其他类型的压力有何不同。例如，你可能会认为收到糟糕的医学诊断会比等待诊断更有压力，但这不一定
what you've found. So what makes the experience of waiting particularly stressful? Yeah, that's exactly right. So just as an example, studies find that if you ask women who have gone through, for example, treatment for breast cancer, you know, what was the hardest part of that experience? Many of them will say it was the period of uncertainty that preceded the diagnosis, not the diagnosis, not the treatment, which can be very unpleasant. So there's definitely truth to what you said. What we think, and we have some data now to support this, is that waiting combines two really challenging states of mind, not knowing what's coming, uncertainty, and not being able to do much or anything about it, so a lack of control. And neither of those are comfortable states
就是你所发现的。那么，是什么让等待的体验变得格外煎熬呢？是的，完全正确。举个例子，研究发现，如果你问那些经历过乳腺癌治疗等经历的女性，你知道，那段经历中最艰难的部分是什么？她们中的许多人会说是诊断前的那个不确定时期，而不是诊断，也不是可能非常不愉快的治疗。所以你所说的话确实有道理。我们的看法，并且我们现在有一些数据支持这一点，是等待结合了两种非常具有挑战性的心境：不知道会发生什么（不确定性），以及对此无能为力或无能为力（缺乏控制）。而这两种状态都不是舒适的
for humans to be in. And when you combine them into these waiting periods, it really, kind of boosts waiting into this extra suffering kind of state compared to other kinds of stress, which may be difficult in other ways, but waiting does seem to kind of tap into some existential challenges for humans in that it combines those two really challenging states. And you also study worrying, which is obviously related to stress uncertainty in waiting. You published a paper a few years ago called the surprising upsides of worry that got some media attention. What are the surprising upsides of worrying?
对人类来说，处于这种状态。当你把它们结合到这些等待期中时，与其他类型的压力相比，等待确实会把等待提升到这种额外的痛苦状态，而其他类型的压力可能在其他方面很困难，但等待似乎确实触及了人类的一些生存挑战，因为它结合了这两种极具挑战性的状态。你还研究担忧，这显然与压力、不确定性和等待有关。几年前你发表了一篇名为《担忧的惊人好处》的论文，引起了一些媒体的关注。担忧的惊人好处是什么？
So worry is actually super helpful. That might be hard to imagine if someone is feeling worried. It's not very pleasant. And that's exactly how it's helpful, in fact, is that it draws our attention to something that might befall us in the future. It motivates us through its very unpleasantness to prevent in some way that future bad event. Now, the trouble is when we're waiting, we often can't do anything about the future event. So if you've taken an exam, you've undergone a medical test, you know, there's really nothing
所以担忧其实超级有用。如果有人感到担忧，这可能很难想象。这不是很愉快。事实上，这正是它有用之妙所在，它将我们的注意力吸引到未来可能降临在我们身上的事情上。它通过自身的不愉快来激励我们以某种方式防止未来发生坏事。现在，问题在于当我们等待时，我们往往对未来的事件无能为力。因此，如果你参加了考试，你接受了医学检查，你知道，实际上没有什么
you can do while you're waiting for that news to change your fate. Your fate is sealed. You just don't know it yet. And so worry in that case can get a little stuck. It kind of doesn't help us in the same ways that it does when, say, we're worried about a car accident and so we put on our seatbelt or we're worried about breast cancer so we get a mammogram. Those are very useful moments of worry. During waiting periods, it doesn't quite have that same useful function.
在等待那个改变你命运的新闻的同时，你能做些什么。你的命运已定。你只是还不知道。因此，在这种情况下，担忧可能会有点卡住。它在很多方面对我们没有帮助，比如说，当我们担心车祸时，我们系上安全带，或者我们担心乳腺癌，所以我们去做了乳房X光检查。那些是非常有用的担忧时刻。在等待期间，它并没有发挥完全相同的有用功能。
and that is, I think, one of the other things that makes waiting so hard. So it's almost a kind of controlled worry, a worry under the circumstances that is going to protect you. That's right. And it's not to say that worry has no function in, for example, waiting periods. One of the things that worry can prompt us to do is to, for example, plan out, you know, maybe worst-case scenarios and make sure we're ready for them. So it's not exactly prevention. It's not quite the job worry wants to do for us. but it still can be useful to kind of get your ducks in a row, make sure that you're prepared for the worst case. And that can be a little bit comforting. It feels like grabbing back some control from the universe in these moments where we have so little control.
我认为，这也是让等待变得如此艰难的原因之一。所以这几乎是一种受控的担忧，在保护你的情况下的担忧。没错。这并不是说担忧在例如等待期间没有作用。担忧促使我们做的事情之一是，例如，制定计划，你知道，可能是最坏情况的计划，并确保我们为它们做好准备。所以这不完全是预防。这不完全是担忧想要为我们做的工作。但这对于整理思绪、确保为最坏情况做好准备仍然很有用。这可以带来一点安慰。在这些我们几乎无法掌控的时刻，这感觉就像是从宇宙中夺回了一些掌控权。
You've talked before about how some of your research started as me search, which is a great term we've heard other guests use on this podcast. What were the situations in your own life that inspired your interest in this topic? I am certainly a worrier by nature, as so many people are. get it from my mom. So we share that in common. So that's been kind of, you know, a lifelong reality. I think, you know, to some extent, everyone has their moments of worry, but mine might be a little more profound than others. There have been, though, also some very specific experiences that I think informed my work on waiting and worry. One that came kind of right around the time that I started to think about these issues was being on the academic job market, which is long and tedious and
你以前曾谈到过你的一些研究是如何作为“自我搜索”开始的，这是一个我们在本杰出嘉宾身上听到的很棒的术语。你生活中的哪些情况激发了你对这个主题的兴趣？我天生就是一个爱担忧的人，就像很多人一样。我是从我妈妈那里遗传来的。所以我们有共同点。所以这一直是一种，你知道的，终生的现实。我认为，在某种程度上，每个人都有担忧的时刻，但我的担忧可能比其他人更深刻一些。然而，也有一些非常具体的经历，我认为这些经历为我关于等待和担忧的工作提供了信息。其中一个出现在我开始思考这些问题的同期，那就是进入学术就业市场，这是一个漫长而乏味且
stressful process that, you know, begins somewhere around August of the year before you want the job. And in my case, went through about January. And it was one of the most difficult kind of uncertain periods of my life. I feared often that I would be unemployed with a PhD. Of course, thankfully, it worked out and here I am. But that experience was one that I came back to often as I was thinking about how we cope with these experiences of uncertainty and what just makes them so difficult. you looking at worrying during your graduate studies as well, or was it really just the experience of waiting for this, the first job? Yeah, so certainly my research has been in some ways consistent from the early days of graduate school. I came there to work with a professor who was
充满压力的过程，你知道，在你想要工作的前一年的八月左右开始。就我而言，一直持续到一月份左右。这是我一生中最困难、最不确定的时期之一。我经常担心自己会带着博士学位失业。当然，谢天谢地，事情解决了，我在这里。但当我思考我们如何应对这些不确定性的经历以及究竟是什么让它们变得如此困难时，这段经历是我经常回顾的。你在研究生学习期间也在关注担忧吗，还是真的只是等待第一份工作的心情？是的，当然，我的研究在某些方面与研究生院的早期保持一致。我来这里是为了和一位教授一起工作，他当时
studying at the time one piece of the waiting experience, and that is bracing for the worst, which is a kind of nitpicky phenomenon that happens while we're waiting where your expectations tend to go from very optimistic at the start or before a waiting period and then plunge into pessimism at the moment of truth when we're convinced we fail the exam or we have cancer or whatever the fear might be. And so I studied that phenomenon, as small as it may be, for quite a long time with a lot of focus. And then as I came into this job at UC Riverside and, again, having had that experience of uncertainty during the job market, I started to kind of broaden out the view and start to think about, yes, we brace for the worst while we're waiting, but what
正在研究等待体验的一个部分，那就是为最坏的情况做心理准备，这是一种挑剔的现象，发生在等待期间，你的期望往往从开始时或等待期之前的非常乐观，然后一落千丈，在真相大白的那一刻陷入悲观，当时我们确信自己考试不及格，或者我们得了癌症，或者无论可能是什么恐惧。因此，无论多么微不足道，我都非常专注地研究这种现象很长一段时间。然后，当我来到加州大学河滨分校担任这个职位时，同样，由于在就业市场上有过那种不确定性的经历，我开始拓宽视野，开始思考，是的，我们在等待的时候会为最坏的情况做准备，但是什么
else are we doing? And what else is going on during those experiences that makes it so difficult? So that was kind of the evolution of my research program. There's a stereotype that women are bigger worriers than men. Is there any truth to that? Is waiting for uncertain news more difficult for some people than for others? And how does personality or other demographic factors figure into worrying? So we actually did publish a paper just a few years ago with some pretty convincing evidence that women report more worried than men. I think that's a pretty important distinction. It may be that for various reasons, be they evolutionary or socialization, kind of how we're raised, that women may, on average, perhaps experience a bit more of that particular kind of negative emotional experience.
我们在等待那些经历时还在做什么？是什么让这些经历变得如此困难？这就是我的研究项目的演变过程。有一个刻板印象，即女性比男性更会担忧。这有道理吗？对于某些人来说，等待不确定的消息是否比其他人更困难？人格或其他人口统计因素在担忧中扮演什么角色？事实上，就在几年前，我们确实发表了一篇论文，其中有一些非常令人信服的证据，表明女性报告的担忧比男性多。我认为这是一个非常重要的区别。原因可能多种多样，无论是出于进化还是社会化，比如我们的成长方式，女性平均可能会经历更多这种特定的负面情绪体验。
But it's a little bit hard to parse that out because it is also the case that women learn from an early age, very, very, very. early age, in fact, research shows that, you know, it's kind of okay to cry and it's okay to be worried and it's okay to be anxious and, you know, little boys may be less so. Certainly that was true. Historically, I would like to think maybe that's changing, but it's a pretty pervasive gender difference in how we raise kids. So I think that, yes, there is quite a bit of evidence, again, that women are at least willing to report more worry than men. It's also the case that personality matters. So people who have an overall tendency towards what psychologists call neuroticism, which is essentially emotional instability combined with a negative
但这有点难以剖析，因为事实也是如此，女性从小就学会了，非常非常非常。事实上，研究表明，早期的年龄是，你知道的，哭是可以的，担心是可以的，焦虑是可以的，你知道的，小男孩可能没那么严重。历史上的确如此。我想认为也许这正在改变，但在我们抚养孩子的方式中，这是一个非常普遍的性别差异。所以我认为，是的，有相当多的证据再次表明，女性至少愿意报告比男性更多的担忧。事实也是如此，个性很重要。因此，总体倾向于心理学家所说的神经质的人，本质上是情绪不稳定与负面情绪相结合的人。
emotional kind of tendency. Unsurprisingly, those folks tend to deal with more worried than folks who are less neurotic or less lower in neuroticism. There are other kinds of individual differences we would refer to them as that matter. One big one is what we call dispositional optimism. And that just means kind of an overall tendency to be bright and cheery and kind of expect the best. And even if it doesn't work out the way you want, it's going to be okay anyway. You know, those annoyingly happy folks that we all know, the higher you are in that tendency, that dispositional optimism, the easier time you have in the face of uncertainty. Now, having said all of that, no one finds all uncertainty to be comfortable.
情绪倾向。毫不奇怪，这些人往往比神经质程度较低或神经质程度较低的人处理更多的担忧。我们所说的其他类型的人口统计学差异也很重要。其中一个大问题就是我们所说的性格乐观。这只是一种总体倾向，即开朗、快活并期待最好。即使事情没有按照你希望的那样发展，无论如何一切都会好起来的。你知道，我们都知道那些令人讨厌的快乐的人，你在那种倾向（性格乐观）上的得分越高，你在面对不确定性时就会越容易。话虽如此，没有人会发现所有不确定性都是舒适的。
As I said earlier about worry, it's useful. And so we really can't escape it entirely. And I, you know, anecdotally have yet to find a person who hears about my research and says, I don't know why you'd even study that. It's not that hard for me. So I think it's a fairly universal experience at some level. Does being an optimist, I mean, having a positive outlook on the world protect you from worrying to optimists, worry less than pessimists, or is everybody, you know, we all just worry. Yeah, optimists do worry less than pessimist, on average. Again, there are exceptional moments where, you know, the situation is so extreme that everyone worries. But on average, yeah, optimism being an optimist in that.
正如我之前关于担忧所说的那样，它是有用的。所以我们真的无法完全摆脱它。我，你知道的，趣闻轶事般地还没有找到一个听到我的研究并说“我不知道你为什么要研究那个”的人。对我来说没那么难。所以我认为这在某种程度上是一种非常普遍的体验。成为一个乐观主义者，我的意思是，对世界持积极的态度可以保护你免于担忧吗？乐观主义者比悲观主义者担忧更少，还是每个人，你知道，我们都只是在担忧。是的，平均而言，乐观主义者确实比悲观主义者担忧更少。再次强调，会有一些特殊时刻，你知道，情况如此极端，以至于每个人都在担忧。但平均而言，是的，乐观主义者。
that way, that kind of cheery, dispositional way, does, it is protective. In fact, it's, it's one of the rare areas in psychology where it's pretty hard to find a downside to that particular kind of personality trait. You might gamble more aggressively. Like, that's the one finding about dispositional optimism that is, that's negative. But pretty much everything else about it is protective. Now, I want to make a really important distinction, and that is being that type of person doesn't mean that you always think things will go well for you. That's what you. That's what we call unrealistic optimism. And that is more of a kind of situational tendency to, you know, just expect the best when it's not really something you should be expecting. And that has all kinds of
这种开朗、性格开朗的方式确实具有保护作用。事实上，这是心理学中罕见的几个领域之一，在这个领域中很难找到这种特定人格特质的负面影响。你可能会进行更激进的赌博。比如，这是关于性格乐观的唯一一个发现，是负面的。但几乎关于它的所有其他事情都是具有保护作用的。现在，我想做一个非常重要的区分，那就是成为那种类型的人并不意味着你总是认为事情会对你有利。这就是你。这就是我们所说的非现实乐观主义。这更像是一种情境倾向，即当它不是你真正应该期待的时候，只期待最好的结果。这有各种各样的
downsides. But that more, you know, kind of general disposition towards optimism and cheerfulness seems to be a pretty good thing if you can have it. Does worrying kind of level off with age? I mean, there are a lot of, you know, negative characteristics that many people have that as you get older and you know, we always talk about how the baby boomers, the older folks are, they feel more comfortable in their skin, basically. I mean, does that happen with worrying as well? We're just sort of, okay, I got this. I've been here before. Yeah, I don't know actually of any really good data on that question, but you might assume so from other research on aging. One of the things, one of my favorite, I guess, findings in psychology, though it's not my area,
缺点。但是如果你能拥有它，那种更普遍的对乐观和开朗的性格倾向似乎是一件非常好的事情。随着年龄的增长，担忧会逐渐平息吗？我的意思是，许多人都有很多消极特征，随着年龄的增长，你知道，我们总是谈论婴儿潮一代，老年人，他们基本上对自己的皮肤感觉更舒服。我的意思是，担忧也会发生这种情况吗？我们只是有点，好吧，我明白了。我以前来过这里。是的，实际上我不知道关于这个问题的任何真正好的数据，但你可以从其他关于衰老的研究中推测出来。其中一件事，我最喜欢的心理学发现之一，尽管这不是我的领域，
really, is that we do generally tend to get happier as we get older, at least from sort of the point of middle age onto later adulthood and older old age. It's maybe counterintuitive, but it's, the evidence is pretty compelling. And there are lots of good reasons why, you know, as you said, you kind of get a better perspective. You're a little bit less concerned about kind of, you know, achievement and making remark on the world and kind of settling in more to a comfortable place in life. That's, you know, not entirely a faithful interpretation of the very complicated research on that topic. But it's very reassuring for me to know that, you know, likely I will get happier as I get older. It's a one thing to look forward to. And, you know,
真的，随着年龄的增长，我们通常会变得更快乐，至少从中年到晚年和老年。这也许是违反直觉的，但证据相当令人信服。有很多很好的理由，正如你所说，你会获得更好的视角。你对成就和对世界的评价的关注会减少一点，并且会在生活中找到一个更舒适的位置。这，你知道，并不是对该主题非常复杂的研究的完全忠实的解释。但对我来说非常令人放心的是，你知道，随着年龄的增长，我可能会变得更快乐。这是值得期待的一件事。而且，你知道，
again, I think worry likely goes along with that. Now, of course, there's huge variability. We probably all know older people who are, you know, beset by a lot of anxiety and worry. And that's a tough, a tough place to be at that age. But on average, it does seem like people tend to, as you said, mellow out kind of as we get older. There's a really old adage, probably a lot of our listeners have never heard it, but it's the kind of thing my grandmother used to say. A watched pot never boils. So does time slow down for everybody who's worrying? I mean, that is kind of what that describes that if you watch the water, it's never going to boil. If you walk away, it will boil. Yep, that's exactly right. Yeah. So in general, we've all, I'm sure, had the experience in lots of contexts where if you're having a good time, time flies. And if you're, you know, experiencing something frustrating or boring or tedious or unpleasant. time seems to crawl along a minute can feel like an hour. And that's the case with waiting and worry as well. So we have found that when people are suffering during a waiting period, they're worried,
同样，我认为担忧可能伴随着这一点。当然，存在巨大的差异。我们可能都认识一些老年人，他们被大量的焦虑和担忧所困扰。在这个年纪，那是一个艰难的、艰难的境地。但平均而言，正如你所说，人们似乎确实会随着年龄的增长而变得温和。有一个非常古老的谚语，可能我们的很多听众都没有听过，但这是我祖母常说的那种话。滚锅不沸。那么，对于所有正在担忧的人来说，时间变慢了吗？我的意思是，这正是所描述的，如果你看着水，它永远不会沸腾。如果你走开，它就会沸腾。是的，完全正确。是的。所以总的来说，我们都有过这样的经历，在很多情况下，如果你玩得开心，时间飞逝。如果你是，你知道的，经历一些令人沮丧、无聊、乏味或不愉快的事情。时间似乎在爬行，一分钟可以感觉像一个小时。等待和担忧也是如此。因此，我们发现，当人们在等待期间遭受痛苦时，他们会担心，
they're having a difficult time coping, that it feels like the end of that waiting period will never come. Now, unfortunately, there's a bit of a downward spiral that can occur because it's also the case that when you feel like this waiting period will never end, it can heighten that distress that you're experiencing. So we've worked pretty hard to find good ways to kind of break that cycle. But it's somewhat inevitable, I think, in those moments where you are feeling particularly worried.
他们很难应付，以至于等待期似乎永远不会结束。现在，不幸的是，可能会发生某种恶性循环，因为事实也是如此，当你觉得这个等待期永远不会结束时，它会加剧你所经历的痛苦。因此，我们一直在努力寻找打破这种循环的好方法。但我认为，在你感到格外担忧的那些时刻，这是不可避免的。
So I think that segues us into the concept of flow, right? That's something that you have named and have been looking at. Can you explain what flow is and how it can help people who worry? Yeah. So flow is a concept that's been around in the research literature for, gosh, I forget how old I am, but it's probably more than 50 years at this point. a very long time, longer than I am alive. And Mike Chiksetmi Hai is the kind of father of that concept of flow.
所以我想这把我们引向了心流的概念，对吧？这是你命名并一直在研究的东西。你能解释一下什么是心流以及它如何帮助焦虑的人吗？是的。心流是一个在研究文献中存在了很长时间的概念，天哪，我忘了我有多大了，但此时它可能已经超过 50 年了。很长的时间，比我的生命还要长。迈克·契克森米哈伊（Mike Chiksetmi Hai）是心流概念之父。
He did studies some really interesting in-depth studies many, many, many decades ago about creative types and the folks who can sit and paint and, you know, forego food and never get up to go to the bathroom and, you know, they'll cramp up and they barely notice it because they're so in the zone in the activity they're doing. And so he really identified that kind of absorbed flow state that, that many of us experience in our everyday lives as well, not just the artists among us.
许多许多年前，他对富有创造力的人以及那些可以坐着画画、放弃食物、从不上厕所、而且他们会抽筋却几乎没有注意到的人进行了非常有趣、深入的研究，因为他们完全沉浸在他们正在做的事情中。因此，他真正确定了那种全神贯注的心流状态，我们许多人在日常生活中也经历过这种状态，而不仅仅是我们当中的艺术家。
And so we have picked up that concept and really applied it to this idea of waiting. As we just talked about, one of the difficult things about waiting is the persistence of time passing slowly and not passing as quickly as we would like it to when we are eager to find out some information. And so, you know, what better to do
因此，我们吸收了这个概念，并将其真正应用到等待的想法中。正如我们刚刚讨论的那样，等待的困难之一是时间过得很慢，而且当我们渴望发现一些信息时，它没有我们希望的那么快。所以，你知道，做什么更好
than to do something that will make time feel like it's flying by. And there are lots of things we can do that might be, you know, a little bit distracting that, you know, get us away from watching that pot as the saying goes. But it is especially useful if you can get into that kind of exquisitely distracting state of flow where, you know, you lose self-consciousness, you are completely out of your head, you are completely in the activity. And in fact, we know that time seems to really just pass by in a moment when we're in that state. In fact, when people ask, like, how do I know what my own flow activities might be? I say, think about the thing you can't do if you need to leave the house anytime soon
而不是做一些让时间飞逝的事情。我们可以做很多事情，这些事情可能是，你知道的，有点分散注意力，（正如俗话所说）让我们远离盯着那个锅。但是，如果你能进入那种精致分散注意力心流状态，那将特别有用，在这种状态下，你知道，你失去了自我意识，你完全脱离了你的头脑，你完全融入了活动中。事实上，我们知道，当我们处于这种状态时，时间似乎真的在一瞬间流逝。事实上，当人们问，比如我怎么知道我自己的心流活动可能是什么？我说，想想如果你很快需要离开家就不能做的事情，因为你会失去对时间的追踪，最终无论你去哪里都会迟到。这是一个相当不错的指标，表明那是一项心流活动，每个人都不同。所以，是的，这是一个很好的测试，真正指出了心流体验的时间知觉方面。这听觉上几乎与冥想状态有关。我的意思是，这也是你建议的一部分吗？那些心怀担忧的人，如果你能像你可能进行正念冥想那样专注，那会有所帮助吗？我们也在这种背景下研究了正念冥想。这很有趣。我想说，心流和正念是表亲。
because you'll lose track of time and end up being late wherever you're going. And that's a pretty good indicator that that's a flow activity, which is different for everyone. So, yeah, that's a good test and really points to that time perception aspect of flow experiences. It sounds like it almost relates to a meditative state. I mean, is that part of what you advise? people who are worriers that if you can focus in the way that you might mindfully meditate, that that will help? We have studied mindfulness meditation as well in this context, or in this context, excuse me. And it's interesting. Flow and mindfulness are cousins, I would say.
因为你会失去时间感，结果去哪里都会迟到。这很好地表明了这是一个心流活动，对每个人来说都不一样。所以，是的，这是一个很好的测试，确实指出了心流体验中时间感知的那一面。听起来它几乎与冥想状态有关。我的意思是，这就是你的建议的一部分吗？对于那些容易焦虑的人，如果你能以类似正念冥想的方式集中注意力，那会有所帮助吗？我们也在这种情况下研究过正念冥想，或者说，请原谅，在这种情况下。这很有趣。我想说，心流和正念是表亲。
They certainly share a lot in common. They are both a form of focused attention, which might not, again, intuitively seem like something that would be helpful, but it turns out that attention is a really powerful force. And if we're letting it kind of carry away, to worries and ruminations and unpleasant thoughts that's going to hurt us, whereas if we can focus it towards something productive and pleasant, that's probably going to help us in those moments. So they're similar in that sense. They're also similar in the sense that they are beneficial
它们当然有很多共同点。它们都是集中注意力的一种形式，这可能再次凭直觉看起来不像是有帮助的事情，但事实证明注意力是一种非常强大的力量。如果我们让它随波逐流，去担忧、反刍和不愉快的事情，那将会伤害我们，而如果我们能将注意力集中在富有成效和愉快的事情上，那可能会在这些时刻对我们有所帮助。所以在某种意义上它们是相似的。它们在某种意义上也是相似的，即它们是有益的
in lots of ways for reducing stress, for improving our emotional state. How they are different, I think, importantly, is that mindfulness is really about total awareness of your experience in a given moment. And that's really the focus, of most meditations is maybe focus on the breath, but also kind of notice your thoughts passing by, notice feelings that arise, notice sounds in your environment.
在很多方面可以减轻压力，改善我们的情绪状态。我认为它们的不同之处在于，重要的是，正念实际上是关于在给定时刻对你的体验的全面觉察。这确实是大多数冥想的重点，也许专注于呼吸，但也注意到你的思想掠过，注意到出现的感受，注意到你环境中的声音。
Whereas flow is really the opposite in that particular way, where you are so absorbed in an activity. One term that comes up in the flow research is action awareness merging, which just means you and the activity are essentially one. There is like no kind of mental space between you and what you're doing. And that's really different.
而心流在那个特定方面实际上恰恰相反，你非常专注于一项活动。心流研究中出现的一个术语是行动意识融合，这只意味着你和活动本质上是一体的。在你和你在做的事情之间几乎没有心理空间。这真的很不一样。
You won't notice anything going on around you if you're really in a flow state. And so the way I think about it is I think mindfulness is a really important practice for kind of getting good at managing worry, at reacting to worry in a way that isn't doesn't kind of carry you away and take you down with it. And that's something that's very useful for sure in lots of parts of life. Flow I think of is more of like an in the moment solution. So I'm having a bad worry day. Today is a good day to get into that flow state. It might not help five minutes after you're finished with the activity, but it will be very helpful.
如果你真的处于心流状态，你不会注意到周围发生的任何事情。所以我对它的看法是，我认为正念是一种非常重要的练习，可以很好地管理担忧，以一种不会随波逐流并将你带入其中的方式对担忧做出反应。对于生活中的很多部分来说，这无疑是非常有用的。我认为心流更像是一种即时解决方案。所以我今天有一个不好的担忧日。今天是进入心流状态的好日子。在你完成活动五分钟后可能没有帮助，但它会非常有帮助
as you're in that moment and your worries shut down for a period of time. What about turning to friends or family for support? Is there any research on whether that's helpful during periods of acute uncertainty? It is. As it is during most times of life, social support is crucially helpful for our well-being and also our health. It's, you know, having people who you know can support you in difficult times predicts longevity, for example, like how long you will live at the same level as something like smoking. So it's hugely important in general, therefore perhaps unsurprisingly, also helpful during the stress of waiting and uncertainty. Maybe the more kind of interesting aspect of that social support during waiting, though, is that I think it's really hard to provide it well. So we need it when we're waiting.
当你处于那个时刻，你的担忧在一段时间内关闭时。向朋友或家人寻求支持怎么样？有没有关于这在急性不确定性时期是否有帮助的研究？是的。正如在生活的大多数时期一样，社会支持对我们的幸福和健康至关重要。你知道，拥有你知道能在困难时期支持你的人可以延长寿命，例如，你的寿命与吸烟相当。因此它通常极其重要，因此也许并不奇怪，在等待和不确定性的压力下也很有帮助。不过，也许社会支持在等待期间更有趣的方面是，我认为很难把它做好。所以我们在等待时需要它。
It can be really lonely sometimes, especially if you're waiting for something very personal. But people aren't always great at providing social support in those moments where, you know, nothing is really happening. Like you're waiting for that test result to come back. You know, people might feel like, I don't know, just wait. Like, it's coming. You'll know in a day or two, you know, how this is going to turn out. Why are you thinking about it right now? Well, we've all been there.
有时会感到非常孤独，特别是如果你在等待非常私人的事情。但在那些“什么都没有真正发生”的时刻，人们并不总是很擅长提供社会支持。就像你在等待测试结果出来一样。你知道，人们可能会觉得，我不知道，等着吧。就像，它要来了。你会在一两天内知道，你知道，结果会怎样。你现在为什么要想它？好吧，我们都去过那里。
We know you can't not think about it. But as a, you know, social support provider, those moments can be really challenging. And we have found, in fact, that in a prolonged waiting period, specifically where law school graduates were waiting for their bar exam results for four long, torturous months, you know, their romantic partners did a pretty good job. supporting them shortly after the exam, you know, when there was stuff to talk about, essentially, and then right before they got their results, in the middle of that four months, they still needed the support. They weren't always doing well, and their romantic partners weren't showing up for them
我们知道你不能不去想它。但作为一个社会支持提供者，这些时刻可能真的很有挑战性。事实上，我们发现，在一个漫长的等待期里，特别是法学硕士毕业生等待了整整四个长达四个月的痛苦的律师考试结果，你知道，他们的浪漫伴侣做得很好。在考试后不久支持他们，你知道，当有事情要谈的时候，基本上，就在他们得到结果之前，在这四个月的正中间，他们仍然需要支持。他们并不总是做得很好，而他们的浪漫伴侣也没有出现支持他们
quite as much as they wanted them to in those moments. That makes sense. So you choose carefully who you're going to confide in and who's going to be your support. Spread them out. So this year has been marked by intense uncertainty and stress for many of us. At one point, we thought the pandemic might be over, but then the Delta variant showed up and breakthrough infections. Is it more stressful to wait through a period of uncertainty without knowing the end date like the pandemic as opposed to something like the bar exam results where there's a date? You know that you're going to get an answer on a certain date. Yeah, that's right. So it's been interesting, actually, for me, just personally as a researcher,
在那些时刻，他们想要的程度远远不够。这说得通。所以你要仔细选择你要向谁吐露心声，谁将成为你的支持。把他们分散开来。因此，今年对我们许多人来说，以强烈的不确定性和压力为标志。有一段时间，我们以为大流行可能已经结束，但随后德尔塔变异株出现了，并发生了突破性感染。在没有结束日期的情况下度过一段不确定性时期（例如大流行），是否比像律师考试结果这样有日期的时期更有压力？你知道你会在某个日期得到答案。是的，这很正确。所以，实际上，对我个人作为一个研究者来说，这很有趣，
or to think about how my work on waiting applies to this, you know, global and very open-ended kind of uncertainty that we're experiencing. And as you pointed out, not just open-ended, but kind of almost cyclical where we have these periods where things seem to be going well and we think we might be out of it and then we're plunged back into uncertainty again. You know, I think there is a similarity in many ways across different kinds of uncertainty, whether they are those structured sorts of waiting periods that I typically study where the end is known, or at least the end date is known, if not the result, versus, you know, this kind of
或者思考我关于等待的工作如何适用于我们正在经历的这种全球性和非常开放式的不确定性。正如你所指出的，不仅是开放式的，而且几乎是周期性的，我们经历了这些时期，事情似乎进展顺利，我们认为我们可能已经走出了困境，然后我们又陷入了不确定性之中。你知道，我认为在许多不同类型的不确定性之间存在着相似之处，无论是那些我通常研究的有结构的等待期，其中结束是已知的，或者至少结束日期是已知的结果，还是，你知道，这种
situation with COVID and so many other things where it's kind of open-ended. We've, for example, looked at cancer survivors experiences as well, which is a different kind of open-ended uncertainty where it might come back or not, but you really don't know when that might happen. You know, whether it's harder or easier is a little tricky, I think, to be sure about. when we know that a waiting period will end, those last moments, hours, days, weeks, however, kind of it falls within your particular waiting period can be pretty torturous. You know, those final moments of truth, we all have a tendency to, you know, plunge into pessimism, plunge into a worst case scenario thinking to kind of have a difficult time coping.
新冠肺炎和许多其他开放式的情况。例如，我们还研究了癌症幸存者的经历，这是另一种开放式的不确定性，它可能会复发也可能不会，但你真的不知道那什么时候会发生。这更难还是更容易，有点棘手，我认为很难确定。当我们知道等待期会结束时，最后时刻、几小时、几天、几周，无论它如何落在你的特定等待期内，都可能是相当痛苦的。你知道，在真相大白的最后时刻，我们都有倾向，你知道，陷入悲观，陷入最难以应付的最坏情况思维。
When there's no clear end, you don't kind of have that ramp up of distress in that same way. but you also don't get that kind of relief and maybe the middle of the waiting period, which is typically an easier time. We have found that waiting has a shape such that the beginning and end is the hardest and the middle tends to be easier. When you're in one of these like endless waiting periods, like we're all in now for the, you know, end of a global pandemic, I don't even know what that will look like. You know, it's really hard to kind of know at what point you should be gearing up for the moment
当没有明确的结束时，你就不会以同样的方式感受到痛苦的加剧。但你也不会得到那种缓解，也许是在等待期的中间，这通常是一个比较轻松的时间。我们发现等待有一个形状，使得开始和结束是最困难的，而中间往往更容易。当你处于这些无休止的等待期之一时，就像我们现在所有人都在为全球大流行的结束而等待一样，我什至不知道那会是什么样子。你知道，很难知道你应该在哪个点为那一刻做好准备
of truth. Like there just is no moment of truth at this point. Or there are many of them, I guess, maybe. but no one singular end to our uncertainty. So the way that I've at least observed it, again, somewhat anecdotally, not so much in data, is that I think that it creates more of a good day, bad day situation where rather than kind of settling into more of a pattern
真相。就像现在根本没有真相大白的那一刻。或者我想有很多。但没有单一的结局来结束我们的不确定性。所以我至少观察到的方式，再次有些凭经验，而不是太多数据，是，我认为这创造了更多的好日子、坏日子情况，而不是陷入更多的模式
where it's hard at the beginning, you calm down a bit, and then it gets hard at the end, we just kind of do a bunch of little cycles of, you know, oh, hey, this is where we are, I'm kind of used to it. I've got my situation settled in a way that's comfortable, and then a week of, oh, no, this is awful and I can't handle this. And, you know, when will my kids get to go back to school? Or when will my job, you know, become in person again?
在那里，一开始很困难，你冷静了一点，然后结束时变得困难，我们只是经历了一堆小循环，你知道，哦，嘿，这就是我们所处的位置，我已经习惯了。我已经把我的情况以一种舒适的方式安顿下来了，然后经历了一个星期的“哦，不，这太糟糕了，我无法处理这个”。而且，你知道，我的孩子们什么时候才能回去上学？或者我的工作什么时候，你知道，再次成为面对面的？
Or when will I get my job back? And so I think it's unfortunately hard to find real relief for any length of time when the situation is constantly evolving and there's no clear end in sight. So what are you working on now? And what are the next big questions that you want to answer? Yeah, I've been thinking a lot about that. You know, I've been studying this very focused question about like, what is this thing that is waiting? and how do we make it easier for about 10 years now?
或者我什么时候能拿回我的工作？所以我认为不幸的是，当情况不断演变且看不到明确的尽头时，很难找到任何长时间的真正缓解。那么你现在在做什么？你想回答的下一个重大问题是什么？是的，我一直在思考很多。你知道，我已经研究了大约 10 年这个非常集中的问题，比如，什么是等待？我们如何让它变得更容易？
And, you know, it's felt like a big question at times. But I think after about a decade, we've answered a lot of the questions that I kind of had at the beginning. There's more to do. But I think we know a lot now about waiting that we didn't know a decade ago. And so I've started to think about where to next. And there's really three big areas that my lab is focusing on now. One is flow, which we've already talked about. And it turns out that the world of flow research is huge and wild and wacky.
而且，你知道，有时感觉这是一个大问题。但我认为大约十年后，我回答了很多一开始就有的问题。还有更多的事情要做。但我认为我们现在对等待的了解比十年前要多。所以我开始考虑下一步去哪里。我的实验室现在主要关注三个大领域。一个是心流，我们已经讨论过了。事实证明，心流研究的世界是巨大、狂野而古怪的。
That's very interdisciplinary, I guess. It's kind of a nice word for it, which means people from lots of different fields, often not even scientific fields, are interested in it. But that means that it's a mess. I mean, honestly, the research is kind of a mess. And it's really hard to know what we know about flow. And it is this very kind of powerful, compelling experience that, you know, we all have and I think we seek sometimes.
我想这是一个好听的词，具有很强的跨学科性，这意味着来自许多不同领域（通常甚至不是科学领域）的人都对它感兴趣。但这意味它是一团糟。老实说，研究有点一团糟。很难知道我们对心流了解多少。这是一种非常强大、引人注目的体验，你知道，我们都有，我想有时我们也会去寻找。
But what exactly it is and what it looks like in the brain and the body, how exactly it benefits us and when we really don't have a lot of good evidence on that. So, you know, I became interested in flow because of waiting and because of its fit as a coping strategy during waiting periods. But now I and my graduate students have fallen down the rabbit hole a little bit and are interested in getting a better handle on what that exactly is. So that's one area. I'm also taking a deeper dive into worry and what exactly it is about worry during waiting periods that is so difficult. And that is work I'm doing with a collaborator at another University of California campus at Merced, Jennifer Howell, who's a long-time
但它究竟是什么，它在大脑和身体中是什么样子的，它究竟如何使我们受益，以及什么时候我们确实没有很多好的证据来证明这一点。所以，你知道，我对心流感兴趣是因为等待，因为它适合作为等待期间的应对策略。但现在我和我的研究生们有点陷入兔子洞，有兴趣更好地掌握这究竟是什么。所以这是一个领域。我也在深入研究担忧，以及等待期间的担忧到底是什么如此困难。这是我与加州大学默塞德分校的另一位学者詹妮弗·豪威尔（Jennifer Howell）合作完成的工作，她是我长期的合作伙伴。
collaborator of mine. And we have some money right now to try to figure out, you know, when is it that worry is hopeful to us and not so disruptive to our lives? And when is it that it really does become a problem for our health and well-being? And that turns out to be, as things will tend to be in psychology, a more complicated question than might appear on the surface. And then the third big question is one that's a big, big collaboration that I'm really excited about thinking about patience, which in some ways I've been studying all along, but more as a virtue. And that's an interesting way to kind of think about patience, not just as like waiting calmly, but as something that we can kind of cultivate, that does have connections to philosophy and theology. And so
合作者。我们现在有一些资金来试图弄清楚，你知道，什么时候担忧对我们是有希望的，而不是对我们的生活造成太大的破坏？什么时候它真的成为我们健康和幸福的问题？事实证明，正如心理学中的情况一样，这是一个比表面看起来更复杂的问题。第三个重大问题是一个非常大的合作，我对此感到非常兴奋，它思考的是耐心，某种程度上我一直都在研究它，但更多的是作为一种美德。这是一种思考耐心的有趣方式，不仅仅是平静地等待，而是我们可以培养的东西，它与哲学和神学有联系。所以
a researcher at Baylor University, Sarah Schnichter, is leading this big, big, initiative to bring together researchers from across fields to kind of bring our perspectives on what the heck this thing is called patience, you know, what it looks like, how to get it. And one of, to me, the most interesting questions about patience is, why are we so quick to say we don't have it? So most of us, you know, wouldn't quickly say that we are, you know, cowardly or unkind or ungenerous, but lots of people, myself included, will happily say we're inpatience, which makes it kind of a funny virtue. So those are just some of the things. we're digging into in the coming years.
贝勒大学的研究员萨拉·施尼希特正在领导一个非常大的项目，旨在汇集各领域的研人员，从我们的视角来探讨这到底是个什么东西，也就是耐心，你知道它是什么样子的，如何获得它。对我来说，关于耐心最有趣的问题之一是，为什么我们这么快就说自己没有耐心？所以大多数人，你知道，不会轻易说自己是懦弱的、不友善的或吝啬的，但很多人，包括我自己，会很高兴地承认自己缺乏耐心，这让它成了一种很有趣的美德。这些只是我们未来几年将深入研究的一些问题。
Wow, that all sounds really fascinating, so we'll have to stay in touch and keep an eye on your research so that we can talk again when you've got some big breakthrough, which I'm sure you'll get to. So thank you so much for joining us today, Dr. Sweeney. This was fun. Thanks so much for having me.
哇，听起来真的很吸引人，所以我们得保持联系，密切关注你们的研究，这样当你们取得重大突破时我们可以再次交流，我确信你们会做到的。非常感谢你今天加入我们，斯威尼博士。这很有趣。非常感谢邀请我。
You can read more about Dr. Sweeney's work in the November 2021 issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. You'll find a link in the show notes on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Pandora, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes,
您可以阅读更多关于斯威尼博士工作的文章，详见美国心理协会《心理学观察》杂志2021年11月号。您可以在我们网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 的节目简介中找到链接。您还可以在 Apple、Stitcher、Pandora 或您获取喜爱播客的任何地方找到《心理学说话》之前的节目。如果您对未来的节目有任何评论或想法，
you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以给我们发电子邮件：Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学说话》由李·韦纳曼制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪汉。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理协会。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。